head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard charts Will
Chamberlain tweeted out a quote from
Nikki Haley in 2020 saying we should all
stand with Bubba Wallace today against
the cowards who secretly put the Noose
in his garage stall watch your back
cowards Bubba has a bigger Army than you
do cringe well we all know about Nikki
Haley's cringe but Will Chamberlain said
meet Trump's VP pick I responded I'll
bet you $1,000 he doesn't pick Haley
Will Chamberlain replies give me four to
one odds and you're on my response if
Trump picks Haley I'll give you
$4,000 if he picks anyone else you give
me
$1,000 uh will responded and if it's a
it's a push if Trump doesn't win win the
nod if so deal and I said let's get it
bets on and he said all right bet I am
so confident I actually don't know if
it's a real bet or we were just joking
to be completely honest no it's real
it's in writing contract I mean the
world's going to hold you to it like for
for sure for sure uh like and I'll stand
by it if it is real but um I will may
have been trolling and I'm goofing off
but you know in the end it'll be funny
if when will comes on the show and then
we can you know when when depending on
what happens if uh Trump doesn't or does
we'll we'll resolve it but my point with
this is not to actually say I want to
bet cash it's just that I'm so confident
Donald Trump will not pick Nikki Haley
that I'm willing to make a bet I'll have
to I'll have to talk to Will and ask him
if he was serious about it but it's fun
anyway and I will you know if it is but
uh I'm so confident that I'm not worried
about four to one odds yeah the thing is
the the Nikki Haley VP rumor I feel like
is just the mainstream media trying
desperately to say it has influence over
the conservative primary or the
Republican primary I think ultimately we
know that she is not the VP choice I
obviously think I've said this a couple
times on the show I think one of the
mistakes we make is thinking that the
only options for VP are the people we
see on the debate stage there's actually
a much deeper deck of potential people
anyone could pick from uh it doesn't
just happen to be that who else is
launched a presidential campaign but I
think you know there's too much bad
blood between Nikki Haley and uh Donald
Trump and I don't think she would Garner
him any major support anywhere he needs
it is that like I didn't know they had
bad blood do they not get along yeah
they've sniped each other a ton yeah he
doesn't seem to enjoy working with
people that he's sniped with I mean why
would you right we're talking about
trust all night tonight plus Tucker so
this is would you have taken 10 to one
odds is what I want to know uh Tucker
said on stage at turning point he would
actually Advocate against that ticket if
Trump picked Haley he would say Do not
vote for Trump so I I think Trump
listens to Tucker that's why I'm on
board I don't think there's any chance
in hell he's going to go with Nikki
Haley at this point uh Tucker suggested
he pick VI Ramis Swami I also suggested
that I think that he would be the right
move RI said he wouldn't take a VP pick
when he was here with us when Sheamus
was on um I don't remember
that was a smart tactic if you're
running for president you shouldn't say
I'll accept second place but
realistically I think uh I think that
would be because I mean whoever becomes
VP is probably going to be the next
president I'd rather see V go back to
Ohio and run for office there and do
something interesting I mean he's got so
much energy I feel like in some ways
being VP would be too penned in for him
although in the age of social media and
he's a loud mouth in a good way V uh
like he would make a lot of noise in
that office and I think Trump's a lot
he's his life is iable like if he tries
to be president again it's a very
dangerous place for his life sure and
he's got a lot of civil civil cases
going on I mean there are a lot of
things calling his attention so I I
would say that that that VP role is
probably more important now than it's
been in my lifetime in 44 years that's
probably the most likely that a VP would
become president which is why Charlie
Kirk suggested it's the right move would
be to make Tucker Carlson the VP and
Tucker was humble about it but what do
you think about that Tucker wanted Ian
to be pres vice president yeah he agreed
I thought I thought Charlie was talking
about me Tucker well Charlie said who it
should be is the man sitting next to me
and I was sitt and I was like oh well
thank you Charlie and Tucker was like
I'd vote for that uh but you think
Tucker does poor Tucker know yeah do you
think he'd be a good VP to do I think
he'd be I I mean there's a difference
between um journalism and governing but
maybe he could do it I mean he certainly
got the got the uh the popularity and
and the people and the goodwi of the
people and that's what you need who do
you think BEP who I don't have an
opinion on the matter I I actually think
that Tim is very brave for placing bets
because I think all bets are off I think
it's impossible to predict what is going
to happen I mean I if if aliens if
Flying Saucer came through this window
that would not surprise me right now I
think H Biden information crazy to
clarify it's safe to tweet this because
I will even said he was trolling uh at a
different tweet so I don't know if we
there's any actual real bet I see I see
but like but my point is like like I
would make the B I don't know depending
on whatever I need to actually ask will
like did you really want to think it's
laws on like making a bet like that I
don't even know Monopoly money he come
there taxes for like you know bet with
your friends I don't know maybe Li he
said that when he was saying Nikki when
he said Trump was going to pick Nikki
Haley he was like obviously trolling he
he said that oh oh okay like he's poking
fun at Trump for the idea that he might
pick Haley that Bubba wall tweet tweet
is awful so badly can't be Dan sis it
won't be Dan sis I think Tucker would be
a good probably a good pick and I think
he would accept if Trump asked him I
think Charlie's right on that analysis
you know I think ER could help Trump win
but you make a good point about
journalism versus and commentary versus
actual governance being a good political
leader it's not about knowing the issues
that's a component of it it's about
knowing how to navigate and I broken
system really like the's move with
strive his company that's divesting away
from ESG this is what turned me onto him
in the very beginning when I first met
him I didn't know who he was Tim
interviewed him I think it was Charlie
Kirk's studio and I was just like this
guy knows how to solve the problem the
problem is Black Rock is trying to to
buy up the world and he knows how to
divest our our resources away from Black
Rock by not complaining he's creating a
new system that we can go for some
reason and I don't necessarily agree
with this I'm just telling you what is
is the realities for some reason the
people don't trust Vic or they're asking
who is this person they many people in
the midwest have said is he like he like
Obama this very very very uh intelligent
well-spoken guy but they don't they just
don't seem to trust him or know know him
well enough like they for example trust
Tucker that's that's the read I'm seeing
by the way I I like most of what vivec
says when I I interviewed vivec and him
and I had great chemistry I he's
ridiculously smart I like what he says I
um he he even understood what I do to a
degree that most people don't but for
some reason the people don't seem to to
do see that they don't seem to like who
is this guy but that's because he's sort
of clear they're R out of nowhere well
well don't throw the race card around
we're too close the end of the year no
I'm being serious he sort of popped out
of nowhere I mean a lot of people didn't
know
didot book you know it's all very fast
that's why I really do think if he were
to you be the Govern of Ohio he can
build this this uh you know National
name a little bit more but also you know
really take Ohio to an I mean you're
from Ohio right like he could do so much
for that state and also eventually
launch another presidential bid I think
it would be cool to see his his beliefs
applied on a small scale first I think
it would gain trust I think people would
believe in him more and then he can do
even more when he runs again I'm so in
the moment right now I don't know if
there's going to be another presidential
election and that's not even a joke so
like I really want the best right now
and he I agree with you that the Trust
In VI is it's vi just in case vi
vi vi uh he he came on he came in like
an outsider and like okay what's his
politics stuff and you could see him
talking and like not really sure exactly
like what how much should I say right
away let's go and then as time went on I
think he became kind of a representative
of what the people wanted from him and
he started speaking massive truth to
power and people are like whoa is this
fake no it's he's doing what people want
to do the Christy line where he's like
you sound like chat gbt when you talk
did you see that line it was actually I
don't I'm not a huge chrisr fan I
thought it was kind of funny but it's
just it's it's vvec gbt yeah vivec
sounds nothing like J gbt right it's it
was a it was Chris Christie is just such
a pathetic failure of a man Donald Trump
more like Donald Duck and then he smirks
like bro that didn't land and he's
smiling like I got him well they skipped
there was like a whole section of that
debate where they just skipped him he
was so amazing Donald Duck if Trump
keeps ducking the issues they're going
to call him Donald Duck ah D my mouth a
little bit yeah I'm I'm sold because of
his Economic Policy VI it's uh it's
getting out of away from Black Rock
because I I don't even I'm not even
concerned about the Left Right Paradigm
the Republican Democrats any of that I'm
concerned with global Banks trying to
take over and fasiz this country um it's
been happening for 100 years and they I
mean you know that the what was it
called the banker plot or the the
business plot they actually Sydney uh or
what's that that general's name um that
they tried to get to overthrow the
butler Smedley Butler these these
businessmen went to according to Smedley
himself he he blew the whistle on it uh
they came to him and tried to get him to
to Stage a coup on uh FDR in like 1933
or something uh these businessmen this
fascist takeover and Smedley was like no
I I love the America I love the First
Amendment and I'm not going to do that
and uh so those people those people that
Etho still exists in this country and
they've been just doing it slowly
incrementally they got us off the gold
standard you know they got the Jackal
Island they got the Federal Reserve set
up I I don't Jackal Island yeah we got
to get away from these Bankers this
Bankers Union thing and and and create a
more reputable country for the people
something with like local trade they
don't want there to be
country they want there to be world
yeah I'm I'm open to that but it's got
to happen judiciously I'm just going to
start referring to they as The Enclave
you know because what they'll try to do
is when when VI says they won't let you
do it they're like aha he's an anti-em
no I'm not talking about Jewish people
when I'm say when we say they we're
talking about the the the intelligence
agencies the wealthy corporate Elites I
should have call it the unpl I feel like
if there was a cultural if there is a
cultural War which there seems to be a
cultural conflict that if we win if the
American ethos wins that people all over
Earth will overthrow their tyrannical
governments and create First Amendment
rights and gun rights and they'll take
control of their societies thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm. and become a
member over at timcast.net